un bon soir alexis un poulain le projet
de loi antiterroriste examiné donc à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
pour commencer un petit peu de factuel
que prévoit ce texte alors c'est un
texte qui était prévu de longue date qui
n'est pas un texte porte une histoire
réviser la loi s'il qu'un sécurité
intérieure et lutte contre le terrorisme
et compléter celles sur le renseignement
de 2015 après les attentats terroristes
donc on voit bien que elle s'inscrit
dans une longue suite de texte on parle
même depuis 35 ans de plus de 36 loi
antiterroriste qui s'accumulent
là le gouvernement et la majorité
proposent effectivement de contrôler un
davantage la sortie des détenus éviter
ce qu'on appelle les sorties sèches de
détenus condamnés pour terrorisme
avec le passage d'un an à deux ans des
mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et puis une mesure
judiciaire de réinsertion sociale
antiterroriste c'est ce que disait le
garde des sceaux
il ya également du côté des services de
renseignement un régime particulier qui
se mettra en place de conservation des
informations de connexion des urls de
connexion de données via l'algorithme
qui permettrait via une ia de contrôler
un peu les sites de radicalisation ou
autres qu'utilisent les uns et les
autres les données de navigation des
français sur internet alors existe-t-il
alex est un risque pour les libertés
individuelles parce que c'est une
critique qui revient souvent
on peut se poser la question c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que ces lois
s'accumulent un vrai millefeuille
administratif comme d'habitude un je le
disais depuis 35 ans 36 loi
antiterroriste qui s'accumulent au nom
de la menace terroriste
avec toujours la paire les prérogatives
d'un état de surveillance total qui
gagne sur l'état de droit
aujourd'hui vous aviez raphaël gauvin
qui est co rapporteur de cette loi pour
la république en marche qui parle d'une
ligne de crête entre l'ordre public et
les libertés individuelles et même le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
qui lui reconnaît que sur le plan
constitutionnel la majorité prend un
risque puisqu'elle pourrait être
sanctionné par le conseil
constitutionnel
mais aujourd'hui les choses ont changé
on peut dire que le contexte joue en
faveur de ce texte avait
les agressions qui se multiplient contre
les forces de l'ordre encore tout
récemment à nantes le meurtre d'un
enseignant samuel pâtit le meurtre
également s'était pas nîmes ont fermé à
rambouillet une policière par un
terroriste islamiste
donc on voit bien que les menaces se
multiplient non seulement via le
terrorisme radicaliser islamistes mais
aussi terrorisme d'extrême droite avec
ces derniers jours c'est celle où lâchés
dans la nature qui tirait contre les
gendarmes et on ne sait pas combien
pourrait passer à l'acte bon on voit
bien qu'il y a nécessité et au delà de
l'actualité il ya la réalité 163 détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme qui vont
sortir d'ici 2024
il va bien falloir les surveiller parce
que une fois sortis ils resteront
radicaux malgré les tentatives de
déradicalisation qui ont échoué malgré
tout tout ce qui a été mis en oeuvre au
sein des instituts pénitentiaire il va
falloir surveiller
au delà de la fiche sc personnes
dangereuses pour la société et qui vont
être relâchés dans la nature alors à
droite on veut aller plus loin certains
veulent changer la constitution c'est le
cas d'eric ciotti mais aussi guillaume
pelletier qu'on a entendu ce week-end
qui parlait d'une cour spéciale de la
république une cour de sûreté qui serait
sans appel qui permettrait de condamner
ces décès ces responsables d'actes
terroristes et là on parle d'une
juridiction d'exception une sorte de
guantanamo du droit qui a choqué à
gauche mais aussi à droite
et puis à gauche la france a soumises en
tête on tire larmes bien sûr sur les
libertés individuelles en disant qu'il
va falloir revoir cette loi aujourd'hui
ces 443 amendements qui ont été déposés
par rapport à ce projet de loi mais bien
sûr il va continuer d'être étudiée dans
les jours qui viennent
alexis ponnet avec vous évidemment on
parle souvent des répercussions sur un
certaines campagnes de 2022 quelles
implications jeu se monte ce projet de
loi 107 campagne oui c'est sûr que ce
n'est pas
non plus anodin que c'est toi ça
discutait à un an des élections
présidentielles
évidemment c'est un thème la sécurité
qui va être au centre des débats pour la
présidentielle et qui joue en faveur
bien sûr du rassemblement national qui
milite pour davantage de mesures de
contrôle davantage de mesures de
sécurité et de sûreté depuis des années
donc ça va dans le sens évidemment de
marine le pen sans qu'elle ait à faire
quoi que ce soit mais ça va au delà
également de cette campagne
présidentielle puisqu'on pose des
questions de fond finalement sur la
place de l'état de droit par rapport à
l'état d'exception qui devient la norme
on a l'impression que depuis 2010 est
avec cette entrée dans la loi de l'état
d'exception est bien on pousse toujours
plus loin
la surveillance technologique la
surveillance globale
l'algorithme à une sorte de police
algorithmique issue verrait tous les
français des drones qu'on a voulu faire
voler pendant le confinement que le
conseil constitutionnel a sanctionné
mais qui pourrait revenir avec la loi
sécurité globale comme si finalement
l'état d'exception devenait la norme est
acceptée dans les moeurs par tous mais
ça pose une question fondamentale sur
l'esprit finalement des lois est ce que
nous restons encore une démocratie
libérale ou ce que nous entrons dans un
autre régime aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que personne ne veut poser
la question et pourtant elle est
centrale dans les débats de 2022
les technologies de surveillance doit
être contrôlée par le droit le droit ne
doit pas s'adapter
finalement à ces technologies qui vont
entrer dans nos vies quotidiennes
et là ça va de pair non seulement avec
ces lois antiterroristes
mais avec ce qu'on voit sur le pass and
i ter sur les lois sanitaire qui
ressemble aussi à des lois de contrôle
algorithmique et cette question là je
pense sur le modèle de démocratie
libérale elle est éludée par les
législateurs qui pensent faire bien pour
la sécurité de tous et qui peut-être
sont en train d'enterrer notre modèle
d'organisation politique depuis des
années merci alexis et pour l'un d'avoir
été avec nous